excellent okay this is a professional
thing here is a professional chair i
look again it's a weekend professional
channel
hey everyone hi happy weekend I got a
question from Anna dear Evan for my
English exam I picked out the top at
YouTube for this I decided to ask my
three favorite youtubers five questions
about how they feel about YouTube which
day hopefully we will answer me I will
be very thankful this could happen in
forms and form of a response letter or
if possible short in the video this will
make me very happy and it will be a big
impact on my exam I'm honored that I'm
the top three youtuber in your life
that's awesome I hope it's legit top
three not like you said this to 20
people you hoping could be more and I'm
like legit top three and yeah we're
making a video response just quickly
because I'm assuming your exam is coming
up soon and you need a fast response so
Nina's gonna ask the questions and I'm
going to answer them and we'll see what
we did what was your motivation to start
YouTube I'm a visual learner I like to
learn from videos much more than I do
from reading or hearing socially hearing
hearing is the worst so I think visual
at least you can see it on text but I
wish I wish there were more videos out
there that I could learn from and so
since it didn't exist i started creating
it and the first series i was around
while in success and showing famous
entrepreneurs it's on my channels fell
upon the Masters and then I started
ramping up when I sort of get a lot of
questions kind of like this I got tons
of people emailing me and i would spend
so much time hours just responding to
people's emails and trying to help them
with their business and i thought you
know what there's other people who have
the same problems why don't I make a
youtube video about it and that would
help that person but also help all the
other people with the same problems so I
said it your sisters were youtuber
see yourself as a youtuber yes I think I
want a youtuber I I call myself an
entrepreneur somebody asks what do you
do that great question and a dinner
event where you've never met people
before i do say I'm an entrepreneur uh I
don't really care so much about what
people call me or call themselves I
don't I'm not necessarily attached to
the label I'm a youtuber Nina's doing
dangerous things back here yeah I
remember reading in a discussion forum
youtube was opened up a back-end kind of
YouTube special critter community I
don't know what the criterias to get in
but I'm one of the few members in there
and somebody posed a question you know
what I what point do you consider
yourself a youtuber and they were
getting upset with smaller channels
people calling themselves youtubers when
they weren't doing a full time or they
only have a few videos up I don't see
the problem with it you know like why
not you're on YouTube you're creating
videos like at what point you become a
YouTube birds when you feel like you are
one that's it you know what are you an
artist when are you an entrepreneur you
should already be one and so I'm not too
attached to the labels but you know all
I consider myself a youtuber are
consider somebody who posted you know a
couple videos and they want to make
something of it a youtuber as well so
hopefully that helps why do you continue
with making videos for youtube and watch
your motivations the biggest reason that
I keep going is honestly you guys like
the fans and people watching the daily
comments that I see and Nina seized from
you guys saying how much the videos have
helped you and change your lives and
some of the comments are really deep and
meaningful and impactful and reading
them every day just makes me feel like
I'm doing something valuable I think
sometimes when you're doing something
like YouTube you're making the videos
like we're in our bedroom making this
video right you're making a video from
your house from your office on the
street you don't deserve that somebody's
going to consume it and watch it and
have it
touch them and so that can be pretty
insular and it can be hard when you're
just talking to a camera but knowing
that what we're creating is having a
positive impact on people's lives that's
what makes me want to keep going that's
the biggest reason just there's so much
love on this channel and I think a
number people commented that the amount
of love that we get on this channel the
the lack of haters on this channel
compared to other channels is really
noticeable and I think that's awesome i
think we've developed an awesome
community and i do it for you guys
almost all the videos I make on the
channel of requests this video is a
request believe life is it requests all
the instructors are requests the top
tens are all requests every morning and
special keep me going mm-hmm i like i
like the fanatics yes it's all it's all
based off of you guys and your feedback
and love and comments is what keeps me
going through it do you hope that you
have an impact on the viewers do you
believe that you have an impact on your
viewers yeah i mean i think that ice is
a last question um i definitely hope in
anything that i do that i have an impact
i'm starting more and more now to turn
down projects that don't have a huge
impact i just feel more fulfilled when I
know that the things that I'm doing or
having a big impact my personal goals to
help a billy much burns that only
happens by doing big projects so looking
at youtube as one platform looking I've
written the book is another platform
just how can i get a message out that
will reach lots of people there's now
much more goal than than it used to be
where if i helped one person one-on-one
I've really help that person but that
may not have a massive impact on a lot
of people I believe believe I'm the
valium guy yeah I believe it i know it
based on the last question like I get
lots of comments every single day like
every day it's a struggle to keep up
with the number of comments between me
I'm gonna Nina um it's it's a challenge
but like don't stop commenting we love
it
I know that it helps and I try to share
those with my team just for you guys now
for the commenters every week I pull out
one on my favorite comments for the past
week and I share with everybody on my
team because not everybody gets to see
it Nina I've and I get to see the
comments we get to livid but there's a
lot of people behind the scenes in my
youtube channel as well as in my regular
business running the website who don't
get to see all the love you know with my
programmer and my researcher and my
marketing assistant you know all these
people who are kind of behind the scenes
that make everything go they don't get
to see the love and so I share your
comments with them so that they know
that they're being a part of something
big as well what's your benefit from
being a youtuber I think my benefit the
biggest one that I get is knowing that I
have an impact I think as people we
crave a couple things we crave one
learning and growing opportunities right
if you if you stop growing as a human
being you you get bored you get angry
you get depressed you get sad I think
that's why most people hate their jobs
you know ninety percent of America wakes
up and drives a job that they ate a lot
of us who does they're not learning and
growing anymore and so that's it I think
being an entrepreneur in general as long
as you're learning you're being you're
happy and growing I think YouTube gives
a great opportunity for that I'm
constantly coming with new ideas new
techniques new things that I'm learning
I'm getting better at being in front of
the camera if you look back on my
channel and saw a video with impromptu
video like this like I just said Nina
this person has an exam let's make a
video that that a couple years ago would
have been me like scripting out answers
and trying to find the exact right words
and me speaking really bored bored and
boringly boring boring Lee and so I've
gotten better and that's great i love
that i've had the opportunity to grow
and learn and then also i think you want
to make sure that again it's just as a
human being you want to have an impact
you want to know that you're touching
people's lives and YouTube gives me such
a great way to do that youtube was never
my number one
but it has become my number one social
media priority and one of the most
important things I do in my business I'm
on youtube every single day I check my
comments every day we post three times a
day I'm reviewing video hoes basically
every day it's just it's something that
I love doing so much mostly because of
the audience when you know that the work
that you're doing is reaching people and
having a positive impact that's that's
the drug like you want to just do more
of that when you know that you found
something that you're good at that can
help people you want to do it again and
again and again and again him again so
that's what i get when you get your like
will you help on the channel what do you
get i'm gonna sit back you can nail up
and into the question you answer that
last question my own d i'm not a
youtuber your youtube yet are you on
youtube I'm just I guess you're a
special yes especially guess you forgot
your video so when now when you get why
why do you get from being you want to do
videos together what do you get for
getting that it's fun it's fun fun as a
good reason to people don't have enough
fun in their lives so there you go
growth impact and fun good luck on your
exam good luck on the exam I hope that
helped I and four members of believe
nation for those of you who are
youtubers to maybe answer those
questions too in the comments below give
in a little more context and a little
more data to work with thank you guys
for watching your christmas happy
holiday that's coming up soon it's shoot
next week yeah that's true ya feel like
we should add time or something you have
the big kiss yeah big lips necklace what
hey watch were yeah let's kind of gossip
this is a private channel
the channel okay that's it thank you
guys for watching have a great day
believe why are you hey we'll see you
soon bye my English exam for hanging
things ok let me know how's that for you
to texted